fabrice di vizio avocat spécialisé dans
la défense des professionnels de santé
bonsoir fabrice di vizio merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
olivier ferrand a présenté les axes de
son plan chez nos confrères du jdd ce
week-end parmi les mesures des
augmentations de salaires pour les
personnels un plan d'investissement une
remise en question des 35 heures ça
c'est peut-être pour la partie à
discuter pourquoi ce maintien des
mobilisations dans le secteur
hospitalier
ça n'a pas rassuré ben si vous voulez le
problème c'est qu'on a bien vu dans
cette crise que la parole du
gouvernement étudie parole donc il faut
quand même cruellement se méfier c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui
alors laquelle je vous parle alors que
la crise n'est pas finie certains
membres du personnel hospitalier donc
toujours pas de masques ffp2 c'est à
dire que vous prenez le bloc opératoire
qui va reprendre les infirmiers de bloc
n'ont pas de masques ffp2 donc il ya un
décalage comme d'habitude entre le
discours du gouvernement et les actions
du gouvernement ce qu'on cherche c'est à
rassurer les soignants mais à les
rassurer avec des paroles à les rassurer
des discours et on peut légitimement
comprendre que ces derniers on est assez
ont fait des discours et demande
maintenant à ce qu'on passe à l'action
et ça je pense que c'est vraiment le mot
d'ordre alors des discours justement aux
à quelles sont les priorités aujourd'hui
les points du gouvernement justement qui
semble encore litigieux après les
propositions d'olivier vers en ce moment
c'est une question selon-vous de
confiance non c'est pas seulement une
question de confiance c'est à dire qu'il
ya deux aspects si vous voulez y ait un
court terme où il faut dans les mois qui
viennent éviter les contaminations à la
chaîne à l'hôpital et donc reconstitué
ce stock de ffp2 il est distribué
massivement ça c'est le premier point ça
c'est pour le court terme et pour le
moyen et long terme il faut quand même
maintenant très clairement repenser
l'hôpital il va falloir à un moment si
vous voulez
arrêter les suppressions de lits
complètement stupide qui ont été menées
il va falloir refondre complètement la
politique de santé hospitalière et
finalement donné aux soignants ce qu'ils
méritent
c'est à dire une reconnaissance et à
qu'on arrête avec les médailles les
palestiniens ne veulent pas de médaille
il valait juste qu'on leur donne les
moyens de travailler j'ajoute que il
faut bien comprendre que des soignants
dans la rue lorsqu'il se bat il se bat
pas pour eux firent ça n'a pas de sens
ils se battent effectivement pour
pouvoir on l'a vu dans le cadre du code
vide éviter de choisir des patients qu
on réanime éviter d'être une chaîne de
contamination il se bat pour les
patients en fait et c'est bien ça le
drame de ce pays c'est qu'on n'a pas
compris que les soignants ne sont pas
dans une attitude de revendications et
dans une attitude finalement de
revendications tout la population
vous parliez des masques fm masques ffp2
ans qui sont dans votre viseur
aujourd'hui on le disait vous défendez
de nombreux personnels soignants est ce
qu'il ya des actions qui seront
intentées justement après cette pénurie
qui a causé beaucoup de tort au secteur
ah mais je pense qu'ils aient d'actions
immédiates à l'hôpital nous avons mis en
demeure
l'intégralité ou presque des hôpitaux
universitaires de france de fournir des
ffp2 aux infirmiers de bloc opératoire
si après demain cette mise en demeure
restée sans effet nous déposerons des
pleins contre tous les hôpitaux
universitaires de france par par
principe et surtout les infirmiers de
bloc opératoire ne reprendront pas les
blocs haineuse ne se présenteront pas
nous exercerons un droit de retrait il
n'est plus question alors qu'on est plus
dans la pandémie en tant que tels que
les soignants continue de payer de leur
vie les carences de ce gouvernement nous
avons le nous avions le temps de
reconstituer ces masques si le
gouvernement ne l'a pas fait bien il
aura qu'elle l'assumé
aujourd'hui c'est facile de trouver des
fp 2 il suffit de les faire venir mais
les infirmiers de bloc opératoire ne
reprendrons pas le chemin du bloc
opératoire précisément s'ils n'ont pas
de masques ffp2 vous dit fabrice des
vies
you c'est ce gouvernement il était
encore le temps d'agir est ce que
sincèrement il était encore temps d'agir
et si oui sur quel argument vous vous
fondez mais il était forcément temps
d'agir parce que concrètement si vous
voulez où nous a expliqué au début mars
qu'on ne pouvait pas commandé de masques
par vous vous comprenez parce que la
crise était telle qu'elle est et
internationales etc a personne qui
pouvait en avoir facilement alors on
sait que c'est faux mais peu importe
aujourd'hui la crise est derrière nous
et des ffp2 pour la majeure partie de la
crise derrière nous et on s'est
effectivement que des fêtes p2 vous
pouvez en avoir en huit jours il ya
aucun problème tout le monde en année
fait p2 psa en à l'industrie automobile
effectivement on a qui a pas de problème
donc il suffit maintenant pour ce
gouvernement de mettre des moyens de
protéger les soignants et ça c'est
facile
aujourd'hui si vous voulez on n'est plus
dans ce débat d'une espèce de tensions
internationales d'approvisionnement ça
existe plus a donc toute la question si
on n'a pas ces masques aujourd'hui pour
les infirmiers de bloc
j'assume c'est juste parce qu'on veut
pas le leur donner et parce qu'en fait
on est dans une indifférence absolument
caractérisé à l'égard du personnel
soignant qu'on berceau de belles paroles
mais finalement en attendant mieux
alors une autre plante un celle du
collectif des médecins ses 19 celles
postées contre edouard philippe et agnès
buzyn accusé de ne pas avoir pris les
mesures nécessaires face à l'épidémie de
kovy de 19 est ce qu'on peut vraiment
intenter un procès l'état pour sa
gestion de la crise et notamment contre
le premier ministre et l'ancien ministre
de la santé incite d'ailleurs l'actuel
ministre de la santé également télévisée
alors moi je ne fais pas de procès à
l'état pour sa gestion
je fais un procès à deux ministres
commencent trois et non pas pour des
fautes de gestion mais parce qu'ils ont
potentiellement commis les infractions
pénales ce qui est très différent
madame busin à elle même déclaré dans
les colonnes du journal le monde le 17
mars qu'elle savait qu'elle était la
première à savoir qu'elle a averti tout
le monde
et qu'elle avait manqué les parties en
pleurant du ministère parce qu'elle
savait de tsunami qui allait s'abattre
sur nous notre suna munich s'est abattue
sur nous nous l'avons vu est
effectivement aucune mesure n'a été
prise
et bien ça c'est exactement ce que le
droit pénal sanctionne il n'est pas
question de critiquer une gestion qui
est quelque chose qui est de notion
beaucoup très trop vague
il est question de reprocher à madame
busin monsieur philippe alors qu'il
savait dit madame bizarre de ne pas
avoir pris les mesures qu imposer les
circonstances c'est ça qui est puni par
le droit pénal et c'est ça si vous
voulez qui a été mis en évidence dans
les temps la branlée plainte que nous
avons déposée et nous reproduisons
l'histoire nous revivons l'histoire
aujourd'hui avec les images que vous
avez là où finalement on nous promet de
l'un deux choses comme on nous a promis
que des masques avait été commandée que
tout était en ordre au début de la crise
mais on voit ce que ça a donné
et c'est exactement ce qui va continuer
à se passer aujourd'hui dans ce pays
parce qu'on a une déconsidération
profonde pour les soignants aujourd'hui
on est dans quel ordre du déconfinement
l'état justement a pris bien soin de
décharger les élus d'une éventuelle
responsabilité pénale notamment les élus
locaux est ce que ça va vous sembler
être une bonne chose vous êtes en tant
qu'avocat à ses châteaux
je vais vous dire tout ça c'est de la
politique parce que endroit ça ne change
absolument rien la responsabilité des
élus
elle était déjà extrêmement difficile
depuis la loi fauchon de 2000 à mettre
en oeuvre et on a fait toute une
communication autour d'une prétendue
audois mme lichti parce que tout le
monde s'est emballé parce qu'on a plus
confiance dans ce gouvernement mais la
vérité ici c'est que cette loi ne change
rien à la responsabilité des élus qu'ils
soient effectivement des élus locaux ou
des élus d'ailleurs nationaux ça ne
change absolument rien merci beaucoup
fabrice sa division moka spécialisé dans
la défense des professionnels de santé
d'avoir été avec nous en direct ça sur
rt france